- It tastes like freedom. é é é,
et le retour au Canada, parsemé
d'embûches. Après 15 ans
derrière les barreaux, Joseph
de retour en sol canadien.
- Visiblement ému, il raconte
une détention difficile, marded.
pendant 15 ans et ne pas pouvoir
respirer", dit-il.
Le calvaire de Joseph Al-Attar
L'Égypto-Canadien, alors âgéde s
le Caire pour rendre visite
à l'aéroport, il est arrêté par
les tétététés égyptiennes qui
l'accusent d'être un espion à
la solde
anything wrong at all.
- Pendant son procès expéditif
Al-Atar clame son innocence
ououououtient que les autorités
égyptiennes ont obtenu ses aveux
sous
- Today an Egyptian court ruled
him guil
- L'Égypto-Canadien sera
finalement con
de détention qu'il purgera dans
la prison de Tora, re e e e pour
ses sévices.
- Malheureusement la torture est
- En plus d'êsésésésésé
d'espionnage, Joseph Al-Attar
était susceptible de subpepepepa
conversion au catholicisme et
pour son orientation sexuelle.
Amnistie int. Canada francophone
s s s s s trois épithètes réuni,
en prison, on avait toutes
le
subissait de très mauvais
traitemedododododonc de
la torture.
- Pendant sa longue détentrsrsrs
de l'homme reprochaient à Ottawa
de ne pas en faire assez pour
obtenir sa libération.papapapap,
Joseph n'en veut pas au
gouvernement et ne demande qu'à
rebâtir sa vie au Canada.
- Plusieurs questions persistent
sur le rôle qu'Ottawa a jouéphph
Al-Attar. Dans un tweet, la
ministre des Affaires étrangères
Mélanie Joly s'est réjouie de la
et a remercié ses diplomates
pour ll l l l l l acharné dans
ce dossier.
ICI Yasmine
Radio-Canada, Toronto